britney spears and boyfriend sam askari
are ready to move forward with her
relationship
after the pop star shocked fans with her
bombshell statements against her
conservatorship
on wednesday a source tells et that
britney and sam basically live their
life as a couple
under curfew and the singer is ready to
love freely
on her own terms she's a sweetheart and
i think that no matter what they're
gonna know that she's a sweetheart
in her testimony britt said that the
conservatorship has restricted her from
getting married and having another baby
she even claimed she's forced to use an
iud
the singer told the court that she
hasn't been allowed to go off birth
control despite her wishes
and that she also simply wants to be
able to ride in her boyfriend's car
this marked the first time in years that
bernie spoke in court after the
conservatorship
which he's been in since 2008. this is
very important that she's decided to
speak out now and i think she's doing it
because
basically she's come to a head and she
needs to figure out
what she's going to do about this
conservatorship and she thinks
this is the best way to get her point
across
meanwhile the source says that sam has
been making an extra effort to support
brittany
he's been going above and beyond for his
girlfriend and feels so proud she
finally got this moment quote
it's her liberation and it's a long time
coming
he knows how difficult and emotionally
taxing yesterday would be for her
so he planned grand gestures for her at
home to feel extra special and adored
he also has been a huge support
emotionally for brittany
the source continues they have both been
preparing for this day
and they feel a sense of relief it has
come although it's just the beginning
he continues to be her backbone support
her and show his love and he always will
is she the one do you see marriage in
the future i mean
absolutely this is something that every
couple should do
that's the whole point of a relationship
according to the source the relationship
is
currently stronger than ever quote their
love is often childlike and fun
but it is also deep and serious they
have overcome so much which has balanced
them out
but also showed them they can do
anything together
brittany and sam are ready to take on
whatever challenges come their way
business-wise personally and everything
else in between
we're a family ahead of britney's
hearing on wednesday the model took
his insta story to share this snap
rocking a shirt with the words free
britney painted in pink and purple
writing
the shirt is in support of the hashtag
free britney movement
a hashtag that was created by fans and
is used by those who claim that the pop
star
is being held against her will and is
trying to call for help through her
social media posts
sam also added a lion emoji at the top
of his post
the ants of the couple know that the
fitness expert often refers to his
girlfriend as his lioness
she's extremely iconic and i don't think
any artist will ever reach that level